[Music]
heart disease is the leading cause of
death for adults in the united states
the good news heart disease for the most
part can be prevented by addressing the
risk factors here to tell us more about
canoe health's healthy heart program is
dr juan rivera welcome to the show thank
you so much it's a pleasure to be here
those facts is heart disease is is that
deadly it's that big of a problem right
now for america it has been the leading
cause of death for decades
heart attacks strokes we need to be able
to prevent those a lot of people think
those cannot be prevented you're wrong
you can prevent heart attacks and that
is your healthy hearts program tell me
more about it so what we do is we
understand everyone's risk factors
diabetes cholesterol blood pressure your
weight your exercise level we understand
that first but then we go and look
inside your body with something called a
heart scan and we look to see how much
plaque you have in your coronary
arteries you might be developing plaque
and it's a silent process you don't know
it but by doing those advanced tests we
understand your risk and then we can
establish lifestyle or may uh lifestyle
changes or or medications when we need
to to make sure that we decrease your
risk of having a heart attack tell me
about the screening process so you how
are you testing for plaque is it lying
down there's a machine going or what's
the screening process it's very easy
it's a ct scan from here to here okay
very very little radiation it takes less
than five minutes
and when it's over i can tell you
something called the coronary calcium
score you want a zero
but a lot of people have plaque it's the
most common disease process in the us if
you have a score from 1 to 99 you have
mild plaque 100 to 399 you have moderate
when your coronary calcium score is more
than 400 your risk of having a heart
attack is the same as someone who
already had a heart attack wow and you
can figure this out okay let's go over
some simple strategies that people
watching right now can improve their
lifestyle so when it comes to exercise
what's a simple strategy people 10 000
steps a day that's it 10 at the minimum
yes 10 000 steps a day diet
diet i think everyone has to decide what
is the best diet for that particular
individual if you ask me dr one for
coronary artery disease to decrease
plaque to reverse heart disease which is
the one that is the best scientifically
proven i have to say plant-based okay
not everyone wants to follow a
plant-based diet but that's that's what
the data shows the last one because
everyone's so busy when it comes to
sleep what's a simple trick when it
comes to sleep because sleep is such a
key thing routine routine routine make
sure that you're going to bed at the
same time every night you're trying to
wake up at the same time
every day forget about your phone
computers
you know try to avoid programming that
it's going to keep you awake yes just
relax make sure your room is at a very
good temperature in the 67 degrees 68
degrees i love it exercise throughout
the day and sleep meditation works you
need seven hours to eight hours of sleep
dr juan thank you so much these are
great tips we appreciate it thank you my
friend and thank you to econo health for
sponsoring this segment for more
information call 702-848-2875
[Music]